I was reading this Mercola article on extensive this section of anti-concert benefits
confusing. So she quotes this article, um, the person asking this question,
it exerts its anti-proliferative. So anti-proliferative means it's not causing proliferation of cells
leading, helping with cancer cells not proliferating, not growing, not replicating. And then this is the
confusing point, anti-apoptotic and anti-invasive influence via different molecules and pathways,
including signal transducer and activator of transcription. Three, nuclear factor capa,
light chain enhancer and activated B cells, that's nuclear factor capa, beta or NF capa,
NF capa, beta. And proxysome proliferation activated receptor gamma, that's called p-par gamma,
hence, extensive and shows great promise as a chemotherapeutic agent and cancer. Now the confusing part
is this right here, this is the question, how is it anti-cancer if it's anti-apoptosis?
Well, I did pull up that article and you kind of have to read the article. So the article goes into
explaining that actually extensive and works on two different apoptotic channels. I think I've
written some blog posts on what's called intrinsic, the intrinsic apoptotic pathway, that's the pathway
that takes place inside the cell. If something is damaging the cell and can fire this cap-sase pathway
inside the cell and cause the cell to go through normal program cell death. And then there's an
extrinsic apoptotic pathway that is stimulated by something outside the cell,
attaching to different receptors on the cell membrane, stimulating the cap-sase pathway and
causing apoptotic, the apoptosis to take place. Well, this actually takes place,
a good part of the article is kind of arguing back and forth, but there's evidence that apoptosis
takes place in both those things, both through the intrinsic and extrinsic pathway. But the key point
was this is the way they ordered it. Understand, sometimes writers of the studies are the best at
English, sometimes when you quote a study, sometimes you have to correct their English. It is anti-apoptosis
and later the article says that it's anti-apoptotic to healthy cells, but it's pro-apoptotic,
stimulating both the intrinsic and the extrinsic apoptotic pathway in cancer cells. So yes,
a little bit confusing. You had to dig it and read the article a little bit deeper,
says the results obtained by song among others show that the significant peak hydro-diploid
indicative of apoptosis. So apoptosis is where the cell goes through these what are called
blembeens, where it starts to break apart. So apoptosis is a normal program cell that's enough to get
too deep into histology, but the cell starts to blem or convalute it on itself and break apart.
Actually, it's a recycling of cell material. So cell material, all the
the insides of the cell is filled with 1000 mitochondria and ribosome and reticular activating
organelles. All these different organelles, these giant, I think of inside of a cell like inside
it, it's as busy as what's going on in New York City. You'd hate to have all the benefits of what's
going on in New York City be destroyed by a nuclear bomb. That's a different way a cell could die.
A cell could die through the crisis, which is an unhealthy cell death. Like if you were poisoned,
that's not normal program cell death. The cell just breaks apart and all the cell material
spills out and and then your body has to deal with that material and detoxify it and you can become sick
from the cell death material itself and you can develop, you know, a immune reaction to that and
that's what's called a herb cyber reaction, where the cell just kind of explodes, breaks apart and
you get sick. That's partly what happens when you do chemotherapy. It's causing the crisis,
it's causing it a pathological death of a cell where apoptosis, apoptosis is not a pathological
death of the cell. It's a normal program death of the cell so it goes through different phases of
blebbing to actually recycle the material and the hypo diploid phase of apoptosis is part of that
blebbing. Sorry, you probably didn't want to know that. Detected by flow centenometry,
when the cells were treated with this so they were purposely treated with an oxidative agent in order
for this to take place, et cetera, et cetera. And it goes on here, it induces a capsule mediated
mitochondrial apoptosis that's part of the intrinsic apoptotic pathway. And then later it says
it's regulated in the game descriptions in how that's actually happening to cancer cells.
This example was written in phoma. So in cancer cells, it produces apoptosis in healthy cells and
actually protects from apoptosis, early apoptosis. And if you read that whole article, you'd probably
better read that it actually protects from a chronic death of the cell. It would have been a better
terminology because ecstasytham actually acts as an antioxidant. And they have a whole section,
I didn't copy and paste that, in this article about the antioxidant benefits and ecstasytham
and how that protects against a cell poisoning because that's what oxidation is.